how do you make the business and the
marriage work because yeah if you were
just business partners cool great
awesome but now you got to go home with
that person sure right so here we go how
does that work sometimes in the business
because we're we're
partners yeah she wants to talk to me
like she's right she's like she's
telling me what to do okay right like
babe listen your eyes just got real wide
what's up hey hey i ain't i ain't one of
these associates
i hate that dude
about today yeah right and so uh i say
hey sweetheart you got two options here
you want to talk to the fool in me
you'll get the fool
you want to talk to the king and me
he'll get the king what do you want you
say this
wow please say that again an audience
listen up here you say this
this very moment you want to talk to the
fool of me you'll get the fool you want
to talk to the king and me you'll get
the king what do you want
i want the kid
there you go
yes i do so let's go ahead and rephrase
that question yes